>>> THE INVESTIGATION INTO
DONALD TRUMP'S EFFORTS TO
OVERTURN THE 2020 ELECTION IN
GEORA HAS EXPANDED INTO HIS
INNER CIRCLE.
AN ATLANTA AREA GRAND JURY JUST
SUBPOENAED HIS FORMER ATTORNEY
RUDY GIULIANI AND SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM, AMONG OTHERS.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY IS HERE WITH
US.
SARA, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>>S IN A NEW ROUND OF SUBPOENAS
COMING FOR THE ATLANTA AREA
GRAND JURY WHICH IS
INVESTIGATING WHETHER DONALD
TRUMP ON ANY OF HIS ALLIES
COMMITTED CRIMES IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE 2020
ELECTION.
IT'S GETTING CLOSER TO TRUMP'S
INNER CIRCLE.
LIKE YOU SAID, THESE ARE
SUBPOENAS GOING OUT TO FORMER
TRUMP ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI AS
WELL AS SOUTH CAROLINA SENATOR
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
THERE ARE ALSO A HANDFUL OF
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN ATTORNEYS
WHO HAVE BEEN SUBPOENAED TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE GRAND JURY.
THOSE INCLUDE JOHN EASTMAN, WHO
WE HAVE HEARD ABOUT IN THE
JANUARY 6TH HEARINGS.
JANA ELLIS, AND ON THE CALL
BETWEEN TRUMP AND RAFFENSPERGER,
WHERE DONALD TRUMP PRESSED
RAFFENSPERGER PRESSED HIM TO
FIND THE VOTES TO WIN.
AND KEN, WHO ALLEGEDLY WORKED
WITH THE OFFICIALS IN GEORGIA TO
PUT FORWARD THIS SLATE OF
ELECTORS, SO WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
ACTIVITY OUT OF THIS GRAND JURY.
THIS IS OF COURSE SIGNIFICANT
BECAUSE IT IS MOVING CLOSER TO
TRUMP.
AN ATTORNEY FOR GIULIANI
DECLINED TO COMMENT ON THIS, AND
WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO LINDSEY
GRAHAM'S OFFICE BUT HAVE NOT
HEARD BACK YET, ALISYN.
>> SARA MURRAY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE LATEST.
LET'S BRING IN CNN LEGAL
ANALYST, JENNIFER ROGERS, A
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
WHAT DO THESE SUBPOENAS TELL US
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION?
>> IT'S MOVING FORWARD AND
MOVING FORWARD AT A PRETTY GOOD
CLIP.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO SHOW UP
TOMORROW AND TESTIFY.
THEY'RE GOING TO ASSERT
PRIVILEGES.
THOSE ISSUES MAY HAVE TO BE
LITIGATED THE UNLIKE WITH THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE, THERE'S
AN ACTUAL JUDGE WHO OVERSEES THE
GRAND JURY IN FULTON COUNTY.
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THE ISSUES MUCH MORE QUICKLY
THAN THE JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE
WAS ABLE TO DEAL WITH THEM.
IT'S ALSO, A GRAND JURY SUBPOENA
IS DIFFERENT THAN A
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE
SUBPOENA.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DEFY IT OR
THEY COULD FIND THEMSELVES IN
JAIL.
I DO THINK THEY WILL ULTIMATELY
IF THEY WANT GET TESTIMONY FROM
THESE PEOPLE.
IT WILL TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
TIME TO SORT THROUGH THE ISSUES.
>> HOW ABOUT THE FACT THAT A
SITTING SENATOR, LINDSEY GRAHAM
HAS BEEN SUBPOENAED.
HOW UNCOMMON IS THAT?
>> WELL, IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
I MEAN, OF COURSE EVERYTHING
ABOUT THE EFFORT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION WAS EXTRAORDINARY AND
WHO WAS INVOLVED IN IT, BUT
YOU'RE RIGHT, THE NOTION THAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM CALLED AND TRIED
TO PRESSURE BRAD RAFFENSPERGER,
AND OTHER ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
OVERTURN THE RESULTS IS
EXTRAORDINARY, AND THE FACT THAT
A GRAND JURY MAY BE TRYING TO
HOLD HIM RESPONSIBLE FOR IT OR
AT LEAST GET INFORMATION FROM
HIM IS ALSO EXTRAORDINARY.
>> AND SO JENNIFER, ONE MORE
TIME, WE HAVE SEEN THEM BEING
UNCOOPERATIVE, RUDY GIULIANI IN
THE PAST.
IF THEY TRY TO DEFY THE
SUBPOENA, THEN WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT?
>> WELL, IF THEY JUST REFUSE TO
SHOW UP, I MEAN, THESE THINGS
ARE ALL NEGOTIATED THROUGH THE
LAWYERS AND SO ON.
IF THEY JUST DEFY THE SUBPOENA,
REFUSE TO SHOW UP, EVEN AFTER
ISSUES OF ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE OR LITIGATED, THEY
HAVE TO SHOW UP TO ASSERT THE
5th.
THAT'S NOT EVEN AN EXCUSE FOR
NOT COMING, BUT, YOU KNOW, THE
JUDGE CAN ISSUE AN ARREST
WARRANT IF PUSH COMES TO SHOVE.
I DON'T THINK YOU'LL SEE THE
SORT OF LEVEL OF DEFIANCE THAT
YOU SAW FROM WITNESSES IN THE
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE.
I THINK THEY WILL BE RESPONSIVE,
ALTHOUGH, AGAIN, THEY'RE GOING
TO THROW UP AS MANY PRIVILEGED
ROAD BLOCKS AS POSSIBLE TO DELAY
THINGS AND NARROW THE SCOPE OF
WHAT THEY HAVE TO TESTIFY ABOUT.
THE OTHER POSSIBILITY HERE,
ALISYN, IS ONCE THEY GET THROUGH
THE ATTORNEY CLIENT ISSUES, THE
GRAND JURY MAY ACTUALLY IMMUNIZE
THESE WITNESSES, AND THEN THEY
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY EXCUSE NOT TO
TESTIFY.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW IT PLAYS
OUT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PLAY THE SAME KINDS OF GAMES
THEY PLAYED IN THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE CONTEXT.
>> THAT'S INTERESTING, AND IS
THERE ANY WAY TO KNOW AT THIS
POINT WHAT THIS MEANS FOR FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> NOT REALLY, EXCEPT THAT THEY
ARE MOVING FORWARD.
I MEAN, IT'S CLEAR THAT THE
GRAND JURY HAS BEEN BUSY,
THEY'RE WORKING HARD, PUSHING
FORWARD, FANNY WILLIS IS TELLING
US THAT, YOU KNOW, SHE DOES NOT
EXPECT TO TAKE ALL THE TIME THE
GRAND JURY HAS WHICH IS UNTIL, I
THINK, MAY OF NEXT YEAR, 2023.
THEY'R